[Music]
let's clear something up about the
Microsoft Surface book this is a laptop
it does break in half and you can use it
as a tablet but all the good things
about this or laptop things the back
story here is that Microsoft is been
making the surface pro and surface which
are mostly tablets for a few years now
they're good devices for what they are
but it turns out that most people who
use laptops still want to use laptops
they want good keyboards and trackpads
fast processors the whole deal so the
surface book is the whole deal plus a
few other things
quick spec run every surface book has a
13.5 inch 3,000 by 2,000 screen weighs
about three and a third pounds and is a
little less than an inch thick all in
with all of them you get a surface pen
which sticks magnetically to the side
and does its job fine it doesn't feel as
smooth as on the surface pro and it
seems to lag a little bit sometimes but
it does work they all run Windows 10
obviously they start at $1500 and for
that price you get an Intel i5 processor
the new skylake chips plus 128 gigabytes
of solid-state storage and eight gigs of
ram with the top few models you also get
discreet graphics which means this thing
can also be a gaming machine the GPU is
built into the keyboard half of the
surface book and activates when you
attach the device that's one of the cool
things about this actually when you have
it just like a tablet it's light and
thin and actually really easy to carry
around it works fine the skylake chips
actually seem to be really good but then
when you dock it back in it becomes a
performance monster it's a really clever
idea and one of the best things about
this folks and if you're feeling crazy
you can detach it flip it around
reattach it and use it in what's called
clipboard mode and then you get a super
powerful super awkward the whole tablet
from a design perspective everything
about the surface book exists to make
these transitions possible this rolling
and unrolling hinge which Microsoft
calls a dynamic fulcrum hinge is
designed to make it easy to use in any
of these different modes it's really
cool and really clever and even though I
feel weird about putting it in my bag
with the hinge that stays separate like
this it seems to do its job fine it's
clean and simple the whole thing is
aluminum and very straightforward and
classy I really like since this is after
all mostly a laptop the keyboard and
trackpad become really important the
trackpad in particular is really really
nice it's smooth and glassy and just
works exactly the way that it should the
keyboard might be slightly more
polarizing it has these really mushy
keys that really whack every time you
hit one and some people like it and some
people won't I don't love it but it also
doesn't really bother from almost every
perspective it's a really good laptop
good battery life I get a full day out
of it without trying very hard good
performance even easy usability it's a
little heavier than I'd like but this is
a pro laptop with a capital P
in that context this is actually pretty
light it's also when you need it a good
tablet because so much of the battery
and power is actually in the keyboard
base this can be light and thin and easy
to carry around in court I don't expect
Microsoft thinks people will use it all
that much this way but it's really handy
to have when you need to show somebody
your screen or when you just want to
kick back and watch a movie on
it's also a pretty good tablet because
so much of the power and battery is in
the keyboard base the tablet itself can
be pretty light and thin and easy to
carry around the individual parts are
great but the problem at the surface
book is that the transitions are kind of
a mess
to undock it you have to press a button
wait a second and then quickly yank it
out or else it'll go back to being
attached the dock itself is kind of
awkward to slide back into the magnets
catch early and you have to get it just
right to get it back in sometimes when
you dock it the cursor will just
disappear and you have to undock it and
put it back in to get your trackpad back
the screen wobbles because the hinge is
on here the whole situation of a tablet
is great and the laptop is great but
moving between them is a problem
Microsoft had exactly the right idea
here the surface book is 100% a laptop
it just happens to be able to do a
couple of other things too it's the
first surface ever that actually can
replace your laptop because if you buy
this it will slot right into your life
without changing much of it but in this
first iteration it's a little too
expensive and a little too awkward when
you try to take advantage of everything
you can do
my recommendation is just use it like a
laptop enjoy the way the weird
futuristic robot hinge looks and forget
about all the things that can do someday
a couple of years from now Microsoft's
hardware and Windows 10 will both got
better to the point where these
transitions are perfect until then this
is just a really good laptop and thank
goodness for that